Guten Morgen Linus.
Oder eben noch äh Schluck Mathe.
Schlug Mate zum Start.
Und die Taste.
Und die Räuspertaste. Räuspertaste und Clubmate, ist alles, was der moderne Netzpolitik-Podcaster heutzutage braucht.
Und ein bisschen Schnee.
Stimmt es, schneit an. Es hat angeschneit.
Ja, wir haben heute es hat angeschneit, ja. Ja. Vor allem hier auch wirklich äh das bleibt liegen auf den Autos.
Ja, also ich würde sagen, das Ganze ist eher noch so ein Warnsignal, aber schauen wir mal. Es könnte reichen die S-Bahn schon aus der Spur zu bringen.
Ähm ich war äh diese Woche zum ersten Mal beim Flugzeug das enteist werden musste, bevor es startet.
Ja, Wintertime. Christmas ist coming. Wir sind äh auch schon voller Vorfreude in gewisser Hinsicht, ne?
Insbesondere äh in voller Vorfreude darauf, was äh unsere Regierung alles für kleine Geschenkpakete so für uns vorbereitet haben,
wie viele Erde ja wissen, von so Weihnachtserlebnissen manchmal macht man so ein Geschenk auf und denkt sich, also ob ich das jetzt haben wollte, weiß ich nicht wirklich, oder?
Ja genau, Leistungsschutzrecht zum Beispiel, ne?
Das ist genau das ist mit Schleifchen.
Ja, ähm das Leistungsschutzrecht, das war jetzt, also jetzt haben sich ja wirklich alle dazu gemeldet. Das Leistungsschutzrecht finde ich als als netzpolitisches Thema insgesamt ganz, also deshalb interessant, weil ähm,
weil sich im Prinzip,
Also es ist, es ist ein völlig beknacktes Gesetz so. Es eignet sich im Prinzip oder ist eigentlich für einen Aktivisten nicht so interessant, weil's eh nur,
letztendlich irgendwie um um die Verteilung von Kohle geht, ja. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo irgendwie klar war, okay, äh Blogger oder so, nicht-Kommerzielle werden da irgendwie ausgenommen,
Flaute irgendwie so, dass das Interesse ab, also man also man kann sich eigentlich nur so,
So zurücklehnen und sich und sich kopfschüttelnd das Ganze angucken und man ist natürlich auch dagegen, aber es gibt irgendwie nicht so,
Es gibt irgendwie nicht so dieses dieses Feuer in der Debatte. Also es ist irgendwie nicht so, es taugt.
Emotional.
Es ist nicht emotional, genau.
Na ja, es kann ja nicht auch immer alles total emotional überhöht sein. Ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, was dir da jetzt fehlt.
Nee. Nee, ich ich also ich äh ich ich finde, dass diese diese so rein Aktivisten-mäßig, ist das so eine komische äh Stimmung.
Ja aber was soll man auch da großartig an Emotionalität aufbringen für äh.
Du weißt, ich hasse in der in der politischen, sachlichen Auseinandersetzung, die äh Emotionalität. Ich bevorzuge da die die die rational vernünftige Entscheidung, dass natürlich die, die ich vorschlage.
Also mit anderen Worten ist eigentlich ein Lieblingsthema von dir.
Ich weiß es nicht genau. Also was ich
Okay, um zu kurz zu Leistungsschutzrecht. Irgendwie, wenn du mit Leuten, wenn du mit Leuten sprichst, so, eher Leistungsschnell sein, also hä? Ja. Ja, aber keiner erkennt das jetzt so als den großen Kampfplatz an, außer irgendwie
Bruno
Kram, der ist irgendwie jetzt das äh Ende des Internets äh bezeichnet hat. Ja, alle anderen lehnen sich so eher so ein bisschen zurück, halten bisschen auch die Füße still, äußern sich dazu, dass es beknackt ist und machen aber sonst ja jetzt nicht irgendwie die große Welle, weißt du? Also.
Verstehe. Du meinst, das es ruft nicht genug äh gegen Aktivismus auf dem Plan.
Ja, wobei es aber, ja, MPI hat jetzt eine eine Studie veröffentlicht und Google hat eine Kampagne gestartet, ja? Also ich meine, okay, das ganze Ding wendet sich ja sowieso Max-Planck-Institut.
Oh, das war so ein ganz.
Nochmal die, die sich mal äh geistiges Eigentum nannten, Institut für geistiges Eigentum und dann haben sie sich aber auch irgendwie umbenannt.
Max-Planck-Institut für Immaterial, Güter und Wettbewerbsrecht hat eine Stellungnahme zum Gesetzentwurf für eine Ergänzung des Urheberrechtes durch einen Leistungsschutzrecht für
Presseverleger äh veröffentlicht. Ja und da sagen sie halt, dass das äh dass es unsinnig ist. Ja. Gut, also schön, dass sie's sagen. Hört natürlich trotzdem
keiner drauf, ne. Es ist ja interessiert keinen von denen, die da die dieses Leistungsschiedsrichter jetzt äh nach vorne bringen wollen.
Ich habe auch nicht den Eindruck, ehrlich gesagt, auch nicht nach dieser Bundestagsdebatte, die du sicherlich gleich ansprechen wirst. Dass äh irgendjemand, der jetzt für dieses Gesetz ist, in irgendeiner Form irgendein Argument äh reflektieren will.
Natürlich nicht. Das ist aber niemals so. Es ist ja nicht so, als würde jemals irgendwo ein ein im Bundestag ein Argument reflektiert,
ist einfach, also das ist der Tag, an dem ich da jubelnd äh reinrenne. Also,
wie gesagt, ich glaube, das habe ich schon mal gesagt, so ist, ich erinnere mich nicht an den Moment, dass irgendwie einer im Bundestag eine Rede gehalten hat und dann eine die gegnerische Partei sagte, Mensch, hör mal,
echt sorry, da haben wir gar nicht dran gedacht, so, aber ich bin heilfroh, dass du das sagst, bevor wir das jetzt hier durchgewunken haben, gut,
Gut, dass du das jetzt gesagt hast. Komm, wir lassen es sein. Det passiert hier einfach nicht, ne.
Er ist merkwürdig. Man fragt sich dann, wozu eigentlich überhaupt noch geredet wird? Ich meine, es wird ja auch häufig gar nicht mehr geredet. Es wird ja eigentlich nur noch zu den Akten gelegt. So, ich hätte hier theoretische Rede gehalten, aber ich hab's jetzt mal nicht gehalten, aber wir legen das jetzt mal zu Akten. Wird auch nie einer lesen.
Einer lesen, aber wenn wenn mal irgendwann einer guckt, dann.
Könnte ich zumindest sagen, ich habe ja damals schon gesagt.
Kann man sagen, mein Mitarbeiter hat die Stunden geleistet. Die werden.
Völlig absurd, oder?
Absurd, deswegen hat man sich jetzt beim Leistungsschutzrecht bemüht ja, irgendwie wann war das? Äh Donnerstagabend dreiundzwanzig Uhr oder was? Ähm vierzig, vierzig Personen oder was im Bundestag sitzend, der mit über sechshundert besetzt, das heißt weniger als ein Prozent,
ein Prozent der Leute.
Weniger als zehn Prozent.
Ja, je nachdem.
Prozentrechnung muss man will. Wenn man sie jetzt schon.
Die haben aber alle geschlafen, ne? Weniger als zehn Prozent, genau.
Weniger als ein Prozent warten, auch wirklich wach.
Da war doch keiner wach, da war ich noch nicht mal wach.
Och na ja, ein paar haben ja durchaus äh lebhafte Reden geführt.
Genau, also weniger, weniger als zehn Prozent waren da. Ähm erzählen irgendwie ihr nicht, ich bin jetzt gerade verwundert, weil ich meinen Taschenrechner falsch verdient habe offensichtlich.
Ähm nee, also äh weniger als zehn Prozent der Leute sitzen dann irgendwie zu zu nachschlafen der Stunde und geben ihr ihre Reden da zu Protokoll, ne,
und ich ich habe das, also ich habe das, mich hat das überhaupt nicht interessiert, es es gab dann irgendwie so es hieß halt im Jahr erste Lesung, irgendwann nachts und ähm ich ich hörte dann nur,
der Twitter,
Drang über Twitter zu mir durch das Ansgar Hebeling spricht. Und da bin ich natürlich sofort dabei, ne. Also wenn Ansgar Hefeling, wir erinnern uns, Netzgemeinde, ihr werdet den Kampf verlieren, ja. Unser kompetenter äh sozial äh Christdemokrat,
auch als Bundestagsabgeordneter in der Enquete-Kommission, wo er sich seine Kompetenz da immer wieder hervor tut.
Hat dann dafür das für das Leistungsschutzrecht geredet,
Und er hat das sogar auf ähm diesmal sehr geschickte äh Art und Weise getan. Die Reden werden ja ähm,
Die Sirenen werden ja von Mitarbeitern geschrieben und ich vermute, dass er diesen Handelsblattartikel oder wo das war, den hat er wahrscheinlich selber geschrieben. Das ist wahrscheinlich der Unterschied. Ähm,
Und zwar sagten sie dann, ja äh appellierten sie dann so an den an die soziale Marktwirtschaft und den Ausgleich zwischen den zwischen den Marktriesen,
und dem dem kleinen Mann, ne? Das ist also so das Urheberrecht schützt,
Äh vor dem vor dem Distributions- und Marktriesen, der dein Werk nehmen kann und genauso sollen jetzt die äh kleinen armen Presseverlage vor,
Google geschützt werden, weil Google denen die ganzen.
Presseverlage, die ja auch über das Werk der Journalisten.
Genau. Ja, genau.
Ihren Konditionen verbreiten. Es ist sowas von absurd. Auf so viel Ebene, das mag man echt gar nicht mehr drüber nachdenken.
Und dann Petra Sitte von der Linken ähm,
glaube ich, am ehesten noch so meine Position oder der sagt sie, also auch sehr nah gedeckt mit dem, was was ich zu dem Thema denke, sagte, da streiten sich zwei um fette Profite, okay, keine Rede von den Linken, ohne dass das Wort Profit fällt. Ähm,
Und ähm sagte dann, ja, ne, Abmahnanwälte, reiben sich die Hände? Hat sie sicherlich auch recht.
Und äh aber auch von den von der Linken war nur war nur sechs Personen da, um äh um sich das Ganze anzuhören. Tabea Rößner.
Die fand ich am besten.
Genau, die hat nämlich ziemlich klar das gesagt, was was.
Die ist von grün, ne?
Die hat ziemlich genau das gesagt was ich von,
Person, die sich mit dieser Leistungsschutzrechtgeschichte besser auskennen als ich, auch prophezeit bekomme, nämlich dass,
die Folge oder die die realistische Folge sein wird, dass Google sich mit Springer auf einen gewissen Betrag einigt,
Springer als sie als den großen äh Zeitungsverlag Deutschlands, der halt sehr viele äh Publikationen in unterschiedlichen ähm,
IQ Bereichen, Zielgruppen, IQ Bereichen veröffentlicht, dass sie sich mit den großen, weil Google auf die nicht verzichten möchte,
Während für die kleineren Google eben so stark ist, dass dies sich nicht erlauben können, nicht dort drin zu sein, ja?
Somal die ja dann eh alle nur bei DPA abschreiben und das ja auch nichts bringt.
Genau, also das war so ihre,
Von mehreren Leuten, mit denen ich mich unterhalten habe, hier äh zitiere ich jetzt Tabea Rößner, so die die Prophezeiung, was passiert, wenn dieses Gesetz in Kraft tritt?
Lars Klingbeil sprach da noch von der traurigen netzpolitischen Bilanz dieser Regierung, ja hat er sicherlich recht. Äh Jimmy Schulz äh.
War von der SPD. Genau. Mhm.
Genau. Jimmy Schulz von der FDP.
Erstmal rumgepost.
Er kam dann wieder, aber der hat, also der hat offensichtlich, die Rede konnte ja von seine Rede konnte keiner verstehen, der nicht irgendwie seinen Artikel da gelesen hatte, wo er dann irgendwie mit Code ist Law äh argumentierte, wo wo er offensichtlich nicht weiß, woher dieses Zitat.
Eine total vernördete Wortmeldung,
wo ich's also wo ich auch irgendwie gedacht hab so ist das jetzt 'n Vortrag auf 'n Kongress oder ist das irgendwie 'ne Bundestagsrede? Ja vor allem meinte er dann irgendwie ja wir haben,
Netzsperren verhindert und also es war schon ein bisschen peinlich.
Das war das war echt ein bisschen peinlich, ja.
Ja
Na ja, aber man merkte dann halt auch am Ende, dass es irgendwie alles auch scheißegal ist, weil am Ende so, ja, die Koalition ist dafür und die anderen sind dagegen. Danke, tschüss, weiter.
Genau. Das war.
Alle immer so aufstehen.
Na ja, also,
Es ist also es scheint auch insgesamt so zu sein, dass die meist, dass viele wirklich davon ausgehen, dass da jetzt äh dass der Drops eben gelutscht ist, ne.
Bin mal gespannt, was hier, also dann gab's ja noch Aal, ganz spannend. Dann gab's ja noch äh Kritik an der Google-Kampagne, ne, also Google hat ja wenige Tage bevor diese erste Lesung war. Google dann äh Verteidiger, der Netz finde weiterhin, was du suchst, beworben auf der Startseite. Ich meine,
Das ist äh ein Sahneplätzchen, ne, für,
politisches ja also könnte ich auch öfter mal also hätte ich auch gerne öfter mal zur Verfügung.
Freue mich, was das wirklich bewirkt,
Ich freue mich ernsthaft, ob irgendjemand da äh groß drauf reagiert. Also ich habe so nicht so den Eindruck gehabt, dass auf einmal eine besorgte Masse in in Deutschland dann,
äh sich zu ihren Bundestagsabgeordneten begeben hat und gesagt hat, oh Gott, wird mein mein Netz wegfallen? Das ist auch irgendwie so abstrakt.
Ja, also dieses Video kann man auf jeden Fall drüber streiten, wie äh wie gut das ist oder wie schlecht es erinnert sehr stark an die Google äh.
Chrom-Werbung.
Werbung und wenn man, ich bin jetzt hier auf dieser Kugel,
Seite, die haben zweitausenddreihundertsiebenundsiebzig Google Plus eins äh,
Ich weiß nicht, dass glaube ich wahrscheinlich nicht viel, ne? Ich weiß es nicht. Zweitausenddreihundertsiebenundsiebzig.
Zweitausenddreihundertsiebenundsiebzig auf Google Plus. Ist ein Witz.
So, ich weiß nicht, ich dachte, das wäre jetzt vielleicht alle, die da sind.
Ja, das kann schon sein, aber ich meine, es ist halt auch nur Google Plus, aber es schaut doch eh keiner rein. Also, das ist schon deswegen, also ich,
Ich fand jetzt die Kritik an an Google, insbesondere aus Verlagsseite, fand ich also sowas von verlogen. Ja, also da wurden ja diverse Artikel äh veröffentlicht,
diversen äh postillen da, FAZ, S Z. Ja, die das sehr sehr aufgeregt haben, das ja Google jetzt hier seine Marktmacht einbringt und da irgendwie Lobby macht und so weiter, so breaking News, ja. Großes Unternehmen betreibt Lobbyismus.
Ohne euch vorher zu fragen.
Genau, so und äh vor allem, ich meine, und und nutzt seine Plattform aus, meine, was machen die da jetzt in den Zeitungen irgendwie jetzt, seit Monaten so, also,
Meine Einschätzung, also ich kann nicht einschätzen, ob die äh Regierung nicht irgendwie doch nochmal ein Öffentlichkeitsproblem bekommt, da auf den letzten Metern, bevor dieses Ding wirklich verabschiedet wird,
Kann durchaus sein, dass sie da einfach kaltblütig das Ding tatsächlich beschließen. Was ich allerdings nach wie vor glaube, ist,
dass dieses Gesetz danach vor den Juristen zerpflückt wird, äh irgendeine Verfassungsentscheidung dort ansteht, weil das hat nämlich schon auch,
Die Unklarheit in der Formulierung, das hatten wir ja nun hier auch äh häufiger, ja. Was ist eine Suchmaschine, was ist irgendwie gewerblich? Ja, wenn sie jetzt irgendwie die privaten Blogger rausnehmen, das wurde ja auch eine Debatte äh äh
glücklicherweise aufgegriffen, nicht, dass es irgendwas bewirkt hat, aber zumindest wurde es gesagt, dieses wann bin ich denn ein kommerzielles Blog?
Bin ich ein kommerzielles Blog, wenn ich da eine Werbung schalte, um irgendwie meine Hostingposten reinzukriegen? Bin ich irgendwie kommerziell, wenn ich Flatterbutton habe? Ja, was, was, was heißt das? Ich meine, ich wäre,
Deine Einschätzung, dass Google sich dann mit Springer oder wessen Einschätzung das jetzt auch immer war, mit Springer einigt und mit anderen nicht,
Ehrlich gesagt glaube ich, dass Google äh es überhaupt nicht nötig hat, hier überhaupt gleich schon mal in so einen Modus zu kommen, ach, dann zahlen wir dann doch.
Weil ich glaube, dass sie grundsätzlich davon überzeugt sind, dass sie gar nicht zahlen sollten, ja?
Und ihr News Dienst mag Teil ihrer Strategie sein,
Ja, Teil ihrer Strategie sein, Leuten Zugang zu Netz zu bieten und darüber kommen sie dann irgendwie auf Seiten, die was mit Google zu tun haben und da liegen ihre Werbung rum. Aber auf Google News selber wissen, wer liegt gar keine Werbung?
Noch nie Werbung,
In der ganzen Debatte immer gerne unter den Tisch geworfen. Und von daher, in dem Moment, wo sie dann wie in Belgien, wie sie das ja schon mal gemacht haben,
ja? Einfach sagen, naja, dann seid ihr halt jetzt nicht mehr dabei,
dann verlieren sie nichts. Verstehst du? Das ist nicht so, dass ihnen da Einnahmen verloren gehen. Ist nicht so, dass da auf einmal ein Revenue Stream abbricht, der ihn dann tatsächlich irgendwo äh Schmerzen bereitet, sondern es ist quasi nur ein Teil einer Gesamtkalkulation.
Dann kriegen sie aber eine Kartellklage.
Weil sie dann äh ihre Kartellmacht des Google News als oder des neunundneunzig Prozent der Leute, da kann Google sich so,
oder diese Monopol macht. Also sie haben, du du kommst doch irgendwann.
Kann einem doch keiner zwingen, kostenpflichtige Dinge äh aufzulisten, also das das.
Erstmal äh also das mal,
Okay, also das ist richtig. Dich kann erstmal keiner zwingen, kostenpflichtige Dinge aufzulisten, ja. So, du, Sie können aber nicht,
Leute zwingen, ihnen etwas ähm,
kostenlos zu geben, wofür es rechtlich eine Basis gibt, das kostenpflichtig zu tun. Also so aufgerollt. Sagen wir mal, sagen wir mal die Presseverleger haben jetzt ein Recht dafür, dafür Geld zu bekommen. Das haben sie ja dann.
So, die müssen diese Lizenzen machen. So und Google als Markt beherrschender Google äh als Markt beherrschender Newsaggregator sagt zu denen, passt auf,
Ich möchte, dass die Preise so und so sind, nämlich bei null, sonst,
kommt ihr hier nicht rein, dann drückt Google ja quasi, setzt Google sicher über ein über ein Recht hinaus und und nutzt seine Marktmacht aus, um ähm von den Leuten die Preise zu drücken. Und genau von den,
Und genau dagegen gibt es ja auch in in anderen wirtschaftlichen Bereichen äh sinnvolle Regelungen. Und das wäre dann quasi eine ein Ausnutzen der Markt beherrschenden Stellung. Und da müssten sie sich.
Aber wie definierst du denn da an der Stelle die Markt beherrschende Stellung?
Neunundneunzig Prozent der Suchanfragen in Deutschland.
Laut welcher offiziell rechtlich verbindlichen Erhebungen äh also.
Sich darüber zu unterhalten, dass das dass äh Google die.
Nein, ich meine, aber nein, aber Kartell heißt, dass du da an der Stelle auch andere ausschließt und eine Marktmacht hast, mit dem du alle anderen ausschließt. Niemand hält dich davon ab zu River zu gehen, niemand hält dich davon ab, irgendwo anders hinzugehen. Das funktioniert an der Stelle so nicht.
Es äh ist richtig, aber trotzdem gibt es da Regelungen für, dass du eine so Marktwert mit das mit einer Markt beherrschenden Stellung Verantwortung einhergehen.
Ich denke, wir brauchen gar nicht hier ins Juristische zu gehen, da da laufen wir oft dünn Eis. Ich sage nur, meine Meinung, meine Einschätzung äh der Situation ist, das Ganze ist äh rechtlich so wackelig
und bietet auch Google so viele Möglichkeiten, da Haken zu schlagen. Und ich meine, bis da dann gegenüber Google irgendwas durchgesetzt ist,
Also.
Ja ja, das dauert lange.
Wenn das passiert, waren einfach Springer und Co und SZ und FAZ und alle anderen ein Jahr nicht mehr in den Suchergebnissen,
Und ich kann dir sagen, das überleben die finanziell.
Ich bin mir, ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass Google entweder Google News vollständig abschaltet. Ähm oder eine andere Lösung findet, aber sie werden nicht selektiv einzelne machen. Da bin ich also das.
Vielleicht, ja vielleicht schalten sie es auch komplett ab. Ich sage nur, ein Jahr lang keine Werbung und vor einem Jahr passiert da rechtlich nichts.
Ist richtig, aber dann schalten sie.
Ein Jahr lang ein lang keine äh Revenews durch Google Searchs auf auf deutschen Tageszeitungen das überleben die finanziell einfach nicht. Da sind diese Online-Sparten einfach pleite. Und Google sitzt da und dreht Däumchen und sagt, naja,
Ihr wolltet es doch so. Ihr wolltet es doch so. Ich ich sage dir, die lachen sich eins ins Fäuschen. Die haben da überhaupt kein Problem mit.
Wir finden die Situation jetzt an sich richtig gesehen scheiße und langfristig falsch, aber ich glaube auch, dass die echt am längeren Hebel sitzen. Und an der Stelle finde ich das auch echt gut, dass die Ablegerinnen Hebel sitzen.
Dass.
Es muss offen sein, ja, weil sonst kannst du eben auch neben Google keine andere News äh suchmaschine etablieren.
Das ist eine andere Sache. Da also das ist natürlich das das ist natürlich richtig. Also wir haben wir reden da jetzt auf auf verschiedenen Ebenen. Natürlich ist das wichtig, dass dieses Gesetz irgendwie wenn es wenn wenn möglich verhindert wird. Ähm.
Es wird sich halt selbst verhindern. Also es wird, selbst wenn es beschlossen wird,
Also entweder kommt es überhaupt nicht zum Vollzug, weil es irgendwie auf den letzten Metern rechtlich so in die Bredouille kommt, Bundesrat, irgendwas. Äh oder es wird später einfach äh verfassungsmäßig,
kassiert, weil es halt einfach auch vieles total unklar ist. Wir hatten ja auch schon diverse äh Diskussionen,
verweisen an der Stelle auch nochmal an die alten Sachen, ich kann jetzt gerade die Argumentation, ich weiß nicht, Udo Vetter hatte das doch glaube ich mal aufgebracht, ne, diese Verfassung, das bezog sich noch auf einen alten Entwurf, aber ich glaube, da ging's im Wesentlichen um diese Definition von Suchmaschinen, et cetera, also das ist halt,
meiner Meinung nach alles nicht haltbar. Aber wir werden das sehen.
Wir werden, wir werden es erleben, ja. Es gibt so einen schönen Artikel von Stefan Nigemeier, kurz äh zusammengefasst, was also jetzt oder viele gehen jetzt auf die Position zu sagen, äh,
dass sie sich dass sich dann lieber ein bisschen zurückhalten wollen in dieser Debatte, weil es irgendwie letztendlich zwei,
zwei große äh Kapitalmächte sind, die sich da um um eine finanzielle Regelung äh eine Lobbyschlacht liefern, so ungefähr so grob gefasst. Und,
ähm,
Dann gab es noch den, den, die äh ich weiß nicht, ob das so notwendig war, aber so eine äh Stellungnahme zu der Google-Kampagne, wo dann auch irgendwie ähm,
auf Google darauf hingewiesen wurde, dass sie sich doch bitte nicht als Retter des Netzes äh darstellen mögen
weil sie an vielen Stellen sich auch ähm bescheuert her verhalten haben im Rahmen des der Netzpolitik.
Ist es auch ein bisschen.
Ja. Da gab's dann auch die andere Meinung wieder so, äh wer der Feind meines Feindes ist mein Feind. Aber insgesamt ist das so alles so eine
das kocht halt nicht so wirklich, weißt du, zündet nicht. Leute sitzen da irgendwie so rum, ich meine, wenn Google auf seiner Startseite irgendwie retten des Internets das ausruft und
irgendwie äh zweitausend Leute oder was auf ihrem Google Plus dafür motivieren kann. Ich weiß nicht, wahrscheinlich haben sie hier ähm,
wo ist denn dann haben sie irgendwie noch so eine Datensammlung? Da habe ich, ich habe da sogar, werden da vielleicht die Leute gelistet, wer,
Also man konnte da irgendwie seine Adresse angeben. Gibt's eine Datenschutzerklärung? Drucken sie das irgendwann noch mal aus oder was? Wer da jetzt alles mitgezeichnet hat oder so,
Wahrscheinlich Herr Wolken das ursprünglich mal machen, aber jetzt sind so wenig,
Naja, okay. Also, wir werden im Laufe der Sendung merken, es gibt auch wirklich Themen, die ein bisschen ernsthafter sind noch.
Gut, kommen wir zu äh den ernsthaften äh Dingen. Ja. Österreich.
Österreich, hunderttausend Menschen zeichneten die Bürgerinitiative gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung und ähm hatten jetzt die Gelegenheit, äh ihr Anliegen vorzutragen,
im Parlament und äh freundlicherweise, ich weiß nicht, ich frage mich, auf welcher Basis sie das gemacht haben, war das unter Ausschluss der Öffentlichkeit?
Spannend, ne? Also du du mobilierst mobilisierst hunderttausend Bürgerinnen und äh dann das Heering, das Interesse dieser hunderttausend Menschen vorzutragen,
ähm findet nicht öffentlich statt.
Aha. Warum?
Ich habe irgendwie.
Weil die Debatte darum muss geheim so geheim sein wie eure Daten, in die wir reinschauen wollen. Ist schon sehr interessant.
Also äh die Artikel, die es dazu gibt, beschweren sich mehr, dass es ähm,
Sie beschweren sich mehr, dass es so ist, als wirklich die ernsthafte Begründung dafür zu geben, ja. Vielleicht scheint das tatsächlich so zu sein, dass wir es so machen müssen oder so,
Also ich.
Also wäre jetzt mal interessant zu wissen, ob das üblich ist bei denen, oh Mann, siehst du mal, hätte ich mal,
Weiß ich nicht genau, ob das bei denen üblich ist. Aber eigentlich würde man sich erwarten, würde man erwarten, dass es nicht so üblich ist, ne.
Na, wir erwarten mal, dass uns jemand in den Kommentaren da schnell Klarheit äh bringen wird.
Mit Thomas Lohninger aus Österreich habe ich gestern mich noch kurz aus äh kurz zusammen und der sagte äh mit diesen
mit durch diese Anhörung, die ja eben stattfindet und nicht irgendwie großartig an die Glocke gehängt wurde, ist diese Bürgerinitiative jetzt offiziell zur Kenntnis genommen,
Und das war's dann, ja? Also das war das, was damit zu holen wurde und sie ist also jetzt zur Kenntnis genommen und ähm.
Scheint jetzt irgendwie nicht großartig äh irgendwas zu geben, wo man da äh wo man da jetzt weitermachen kann. Also sie haben äh,
Hoffnung, dass das vielleicht noch irgendwie ein paar Politiker im Parlament irgendwie was unternehmen wollen gegen die Anspeicherung, aber der Druck von der EU,
und von den Ministerien im Rahmen dieser Speicherungsumsetzung scheint also so zu sein, dass das äh dass dieser Kampf da jetzt äh,
nahezu verloren ist in Österreich. In zwei bis drei Wochen haben sie dann äh die Entscheidung von ihrem höchsten Gericht zu dem Thema. Ähm,
Mal schauen, wie die ausfällt und sollte die ähm,
Sollte die auch nicht nach ihrem nach dem nach dem Geschmack der Freiheit ausgestaltet sein, dann bleibt äh Österreich oder den Österreichischen Aktivisten nur noch der Gang zum europäischen Gerichtshof, der ja ohnehin,
ähm sich bald mit dem äh Thema befassen muss in,
weil die Iren ja äh ihren Fall dort äh vorgelegt haben.
Also äh Entscheidung des höchsten Gerichts im Sinne von der Verfassungsgerichtshof in Österreich. Okay.
So, also da traurig, ausgebremst diese ähm Bürgerinitiative, aber das hatten wir auch schon mal, wie dass man damit leider rechnen muss, ne.
Ja, dann haben wir äh noch sehr viel traurigere äh Bereiche. Syrien, wo der Bürgerkrieg kein Ende zu nehmen scheint, seit
zwei Jahren wird dort gekämpft und äh in zunehmenden Maße spielt das Netz wohl hier auch eine Rolle. Jetzt wurde das Netz abgeschaltet in Syrien,
diverse Beobachter des äh Netz-Traffics sahen da einen abrupten,
auf null Balls pro Sekunde, wann war das? Vorgestern.
Am neunundzwanzigsten elften.
Neunundzwanzigsten Elften.
Dem Donnerstag. Ja.
Fragt sich, was das jetzt zu bedeuten hat.
Ich bin vor allem also alles, was ich da bisher zu lesen konnte, war das alles, dass man sagte, ja okay, was hat das zu bedeuten, was ist irgendwie das,
Problem, die sind irgendwie offline äh Aktivisten wurden natürlich dann kontaktiert und sagten, ja ähm also Satellitenables funktionieren noch, ja? Gut, das kann man sich denken, weil die Satelliten
wenn man da jetzt sage ich mal irgendwie ein, also wirklich ein Satellitenablenk hat, dann kann die Regierung den da relativ schlecht abknippen. Ähm,
Es scheint erstmal kein Internet zu haben. Nur die Frage ist, ist das überhaupt die Regierung schuld? Also es gab da jetzt keinen Bekennerschreiben, ja äh was ich bis jetzt äh,
so wie ich das bis jetzt gesehen habe, ja? Guten Bekennerschreiben.
Ja, da ist ja die syrische Regierung jetzt eh nicht gerade besonders äh gut da drin, sich für irgendetwas zu bekennen.
Ich weiß es nicht. Ich meine vermutlich,
Also es könnte sein, dass sie einfach der Meinung sind, dass ihnen grade der Traffic nach außen insgesamt mehr schadet als nützt.
Beziehungsweise sie werden sicherlich äh regierungsseitig da noch andere Möglichkeiten haben, die Kommunikation aufrechtzuerhalten,
Sie benötigen ähm also ich denke nicht, dass sie ihre eigenen Kabel abgeschnitten haben, aber es hat sozusagen alle Provider liegen irgendwie flach. Ja,
Weiß auch nicht, da kann man nicht viel zu sagen. Wir hatten ja so einen ähnlichen Fall in Ägypten, dass Herr Muberag der Meinung war, äh das wäre jetzt auch mal eine tolle Methode, äh sich da zu retten. Das war dann letzten Endes,
Beginn vom Ende, ob das hier auch der Beginn vom Ende ist, weiß ich nicht. Äh hier ist schon so häufig der der Beginn vom Ende worden. Ähm dass man irgendwie das Gefühl hat, es gibt hier gar keine Länder.
Ja, also ey, muss man echt mal also äh wie gesagt, ist echt spannend, weil,
weil es jetzt irgendwie unklar ist, ne? Ähm gerade hatten war's aber,
so dass irgendwie mehrere hundert äh syrische Aktivisten nach Istanbul äh gereist sind, um dort äh,
finanziert von dem, von der von dem US-Außenministerium
so 'ne Schulung in zu machen also irgendwie wie kommt man durch Firewalls durch, wie verschlüsselt man Daten
wie benutzt man Mobiltelefone, ohne sich da irgendwie großartig Spuren zu hinterlassen und,
Die sind so laut Time Magazin nach Syrien zurückgekommen mit neuen Telefonen und Satelliten Modems.
Das heißt, äh da gibt's wohl noch vereinzelte, aber man kann da immer irgendwie sich dann freuen, weil der Einzelne noch Internet hat und irgendwie ein paar Informationen aus dem Land raus schmuggeln kann. Aber ähm,
Ehrlich gesagt, wer ich mit diesen Satellitensachen jetzt erst recht vorsichtig, weil die ähm jetzt auch nicht unbedingt als so besonders äh ortungsresistent gelten.
Kenne ich mich jetzt nicht genau aus, was er da für ein Modem hat. Ähm aber da gab's also mit den Satellitentelefonen auch äh sicherheitsrelevante Probleme.
Also was die was die Ortbarkeit anging,
Naja, aber und vor allem ist es eigentlich ja, also ich meine, ein, zwei Leute mit Internet reichen halt nicht, ne? Also, müssen halt schon alle haben.
Gut. Dann äh stehen weitere Bedrohungen ins Haus. Äh demnächst,
findet die sogenannte ITU-Konferenz statt, ETU ist die internationale Union, der Telekommunikations ähm Organisation,
eine der ältesten Organisationen, technischen Zuschnitts,
überhaupt im Übrigen, ja? Also, klingt ja mit Telekommunikation, denkt man ja, die gibt's ja noch nicht so lange, aber diese Organisation ist schon wirklich sehr alt und,
glaube ich mal angefangen als Telegraphen-Union und ja, da sind halt alle.
Länder organisiert und das halt eigentlich auch genau der interessante Punkt an dieser Stelle. Die ITU ist quasi eine Organisation der Nationen,
dort eben den Aspekt,
Telekommunikation besprechen und lange Zeit war die ITU einfach so das äh dominante Wesen weltweit, solange es im Wesentlichen noch um die Telefonnetze ging und eben die daran hängenden ähm,
Einzelaspekte wie Fax und Telex und dieser ganze äh und das kennt man ja auch, da braucht man sicher nur die Telefonnummern heutzutage,
anzuschauen,
Zu Vorwahlen sind nationale Vorwahlen et cetera. Das ist so die Welt der ITU. Und am dritten zwölften, also jetzt in zwei Tagen,
und äh ja, es geht eine gewisse Bedrohung aus von von dieser jetzt anstehenden Konferenz.
Ja, die haben sich jetzt irgendwie überlegt, sie würden doch ganz gerne ähm sich übers Internet irgendwie einigen. Und da Standards für,
Überwachung und Sperren irgendwie wohl vereinbaren. Das Ganze geht ein bisschen zurück auf äh Druck von Ländern wie China und Russland. Und,
Wir hatten das Thema ja schon, weil ich habe gerade versucht die Folge zu finden, ihr findet sie dann in den Links. Äh da hatte Tim auch schon ein bisschen mehr über die,
ITU erzählt und ich bin da leider so überhaupt nicht drin, wie,
Also was, wie sie genau meinen jetzt äh die Kontrolle übers Internet an sich reißen zu können.
Ja sie wollen überhaupt erstmal eine Zuständigkeit. Genau. Erhalten.
Genau. Genau. Und die müssten sie aber dann also die müssten sie natürlich von den Staaten bekommen, die ja irgendwie sich in dieser ITU dann da ähm zusammensetzen. Ähm.
Es ist einfach generell die Bedrohung ist, dass die ITU überhaupt mal mit dem Internet was zu tun hat, was sie ja derzeit nicht hat und ich muss auch sagen, gerade als als das Internet aufkam,
der klassische Fehler aus dieser ITU Welt herauskam halt immer so diese ganzen Standards und man hat sich da eben über alles Mögliche äh drüber unterhalten
Modelle und ähnliche äh Konzepte, wie man Netzwerke aufzubauen hat et cetera,
und das ist halt alles geprägt, einerseits eben von dieser ganzen Telefondenker und eben auch von so einem voll hierarchischen, durchstrukturierten Ding. Und dem gegenüber steht halt dann
eben noch zumindest die partielle Selbstverwaltung des Internets, die eben nicht sich so sehr an den nationalen Linien orientiert. Und das ist halt hier die Bedrohung, die gesehen wird von Aktivisten,
dass in dem Moment, wo man der ITU auch tatsächlich eine Zuständigkeit zuschreibt über Teile äh.
Oder eben sogar größere Teile der Internetverwaltung, dass in dem Moment eben der Einfluss von Nationalstaaten sehr viel stärker wird. Und gerade, dass eben jetzt China und Russland dahinter äh stehen, sind das für eine gute Idee halten. Ja, das sagt im Prinzip,
hätten ganz gerne mal hier ein Internetregelungskanal, den wir eben auch national äh gut beeinflussen können, weil wir da eben Stimmgewalt haben und äh nach unseren gängigen
Prozeduren an der Stelle eben unsere Interessen durchsetzen würden. Und das kann nichts Gutes sein
Ja, also das ist, denke ich mal, einer der größten Errungenschaften des Internets ist, dass es sich eben genau dieser nationalen Logik bisher zumindest in Teilen entzogen hat.
Und das Europaparlament hat ja auch äh Stellung bezogen und sich,
ausgesprochen in welcher Form haben die sich äh dagegen ausgesprochen.
Irgendwie so eine Verlautbarung oder so, der ähm,
Sie haben also irgendwie ein Schriftstück formuliert, was die leider diese freundliche Frau, von der ich diese Information habe, nicht verlinkt hat, einen Moment. Ich suche das jetzt nochmal genau. Ähm,
Also eine Entschließung,
Das Europaparlament hat eine Entschließung verabschiedet und die lehnen die Abgeordneten lehnen die,
Übertragung in sämtlichen Internetfragen auf diese internationale Organisation entschieden ab,
die EU-Mitgliedsstaaten auf, alle äh Änderungen der internationalen Telekommunikationsvorschriften zu verhindern, die sich nachteilig auf den offenen Charakter des Internets, die Netzneutralität, die Universität Universaldienstverpflichtungen
und so weiter, Meinungsfreiheit äh äh auswirken,
Oder den Grundsätzen des freien Marktes widersprechen würden. Das ist also das, was sie äh was was jetzt beschlossen wurde, scheint mir ein etwas zahnloses,
zu sein, aber immerhin, es gibt eine klare Aussage vom Europaparlament. Da das Ganze äh sicher ohnehin in dieser Europageschichte,
ähm.
Bewegt, ist das jetzt auch der richtige Punkt, um einen neuen Podcast im Rahmen der Netzpolitik vorzustellen,
und zwar den Podcast. Weil die haben eine einen halbstündige Sendung zum Thema, was ist die ETU und natürlich aus netzpolitischen,
ähm aus netzpolitischer Perspektive. Der Podcast wird gemacht von Kiki und,
ähm wie sie ein Name mit A. Wo ist er denn?
Ein Name mit A.
Ein Name mit A. Meine Güte,
Also sie haben auf ihrer Webseite nicht wirklich stehen von wem der ist. Nein, doch. Alex heißt der glaub ich. Schau mal ganz kurz. Ist jetzt völlig bescheid,
Okay, oh Mann, ey, ich bin auch echt ein bisschen zu müde. Wo steht's denn hier? About?
Ich find's hier auch keine Information. Nö, warum auch? Schreibt mal eure Namen dahin. Ja.
Sie haben da Ihre Namen nicht stehen. Schreibt mal eure Namen dahin. Ähm das gibt's zwar nicht.
Alex, ja, Alex, wenigstens, das war richtig. Puh, da bin ich aber ruhig. So und jetzt schauen wir nochmal ganz am Anfang. Da steht nämlich, glaube ich, auch ihre richtigen ähm.
Na ja, äh hört mal rein äh.
Die sind da auf jeden Fall, also um das kurz zu erklären, die sind ja beide äh in Brüssel beschäftigt und setzen sich also wirklich sehr nah am Europaparlament mit genau diesen
Themen auseinander und haben also einen einstündigen übereinstündigen Podcast zu der ITU-Frage und ich verweise jetzt alle Hörer dorthin.
Für alle weiteren Fragen. Zu Kiki und Alex.
Ja, genau.
Beide auch äh äh Autoren bei Netzpolitik org übrigens.
Aha, guck an. Ja.
In Deutschland kann man sich, kann man sich wieder äh spaßigeren Themen zuwenden,
Und zwar hat äh die äh jetzt mal langsam äh Rollen in ihr ihre Netzneutralitätskampagne äh ein bisschen mehr ins Rollen gebracht.
Also die digitale Gesellschaft.
Der Verein digitale Gesellschaft. Und ähm,
haben also jetzt eine Webseite aufgesetzt, in der sie die Netznetralitätsverletzungen anprangern, die Vodafone begeht,
Und ähm dass die,
Kampagne hat irgendwie eine so eine eine sagen wir mal eine Aufklärungsseite, in der ähm sehr ironisch so ein bisschen auf die Einschränkung des des Internetanschlusses bei Vodafone eingegangen wird
und eine Mitmachseite, wo man also Remix äh Remixes machen kann von äh in Vodafone Stil gehaltenen,
Werbeplakaten und äh,
Man muss dazu sagen, also es die die rationale dieser Kampagne ist natürlich einen rauszugreifen, nur auf den draufzuhauen. Während,
die PR-Abteilung äh der desjenigen,
natürlich dann als allererstes äh darauf verweisen wir, dass alle anderen Provider das genauso machen, ja? Das ist auch tatsächlich der Fall, dass äh keiner der deutschen Mobilfunk Provider ein äh per se ein äh neutralen Internetzugang bietet.
Das hat natürlich dann auch äh wie zu erwarten war die äh Vodafone PR Abteilung in ihrer Reaktion auf diese Kampagne innerhalb weniger Stunden dann auch äh klargestellt und.
Und Dienstleistung, ne, dass ihr das dann auch klarstellt, dass irgendwie alle Scheiß.
Bei den anderen auch so, ja. Ähm schön ist, dass sie äh also
der kann man kann man wieder sehen, wie wie sie dieses, wie sie versuchen, dieses Wording eben zu ändern, ja? Sie sagen, Voice over IP ist, wie nebenbei auch in drei der vier Vodaphone Tarife enthalten,
ähm im günstigsten Tarif können Kunden diese Dienste als Option hinzubuchen. Ja?
Damit wird die vertragliche Nutzungsbeschränkung in diesem Tarif aufgehoben. Das heißt,
Der stellt sich ernsthaft hin und sagt, nee, wir bieten doch neutrales Netz gegen Geld. Genau, also er bestätigt halt,
Er bestätigt den Vorwurf, aber ihn halt anders, ja?
Ich glaube, die verstehen das auch einfach gar nicht.
Sie verstehen's nicht so wirklich, ja. Also um ihm kurz nochmal hier äh von meiner Seite zu zu antworten, also es gibt da lange, lange äh Abhandlungen, ne, von diesem ähm Herrn Christian Rapp,
äh und dann natürlich auch wieder eine lange Entgegnung von äh von von der,
ähm und dieser Herr herab äh sagt dann also, ja äh,
die Mitglieder, Follower und Freunde der digitalen Gesellschaft sind wahrscheinlich zumeister. Ähm,
Der Immobiliendatum, Datennutzung, aus dieser Perspektive mag die Idee bewusst auf Dienste zu verzichten absurd aussehen,
Aber es gibt nun einmal Menschen, denen Voice of IP und egal sind. Wenn es diesen Menschen egal ist, ja, dann könnt ihr es denen auch einfach nicht,
blocken.
Wenn es den Menschen egal ist, dann gibt ihnen gibt ihnen ihren, gibt ihnen den mit fünfhundert MB, da kann man eh nicht lange äh irgendwie äh,
ja? Also ist wirklich ein ein null Argument lieber lieber herab,
und ähm ich denke, was das das ganz besonders Entscheidende ist, wenn Menschen, die sich jetzt, sagen wir mal, mit einem, mit dem Billo-Tarif äh zufrieden geben, weil der ihren,
bei der ihren Ansprüchen
zunächst genügt oder weil sie erstmal reinschnuppern wollen ins Internet und gar nicht wissen, ob sie da drin bleiben wollen. Ja, das äh dass diese Menschen dann
mit einem beschnittenen Internetzugang, dass das dann einfach der Standard ist, ja? Das heißt, sie werden nicht mehr die äh die anderen Möglichkeiten des Internets
kennenlernen können,
Ja, weil sie selber mal in ihren äh Kunden, Statistiken gucken können, wie oft da mal jemand äh upgradet, ja. Ist also sicherlich kommt das mal vor, aber in der Regel äh schätzen die Leute ihren persönlichen Bedarf an
Telefonie und Internet ganz gut ein und verbleiben auch in ihren Tarifen,
So, aber wie gesagt, es gibt ja eine, eine lange, äh, lange Abhandlung von dem Herrn Rapp.
Aber es ist sozusagen nach wie vor nur eine vertragliche Sperre. Es ist keine technische Sperre.
Technisch.
Ich meine, wird es denn aktiv verhindert.
Ich habe keinen,
Also ich bin mir absolut sicher, dass sie es technisch verändern. Aber ich habe keinen keinen Tarif zur Hand, um es zu prüfen. Ne, aber warte, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack.
Bin mir da gar nicht so sicher. Also ich will mir der Fall, die ist nicht sicher, bevor man's nicht selber überprüft hat. Das mal so ganz nebenbei.
Ich schaue mal ganz kurz.
Nee, also ich bin mir also ich bin ähm in dieser ganzen äh Kampagne der Untersuchung auch nicht großartig involviert
Äh ich muss allerdings natürlich hier den äh Disclaimer anbringen, dass ich äh Mitglied des Vereins bin,
und ähm auch ein Teil dieser Kampagne unter einer Domain stattfindet, die ich einmal gekauft habe. Ich habe aber ansonsten äh mit dieser Kampagne
an dieser Kampagne nicht mitgewirkt,
Aber man kann das auf jeden Fall mit sehr viel Interesse äh oder man ist ganz interessant, das zu lesen, wer äh da mal die die beiden Argumentationen sehen möchte, die den gleichen technischen Sachverhalt beschreiben und ähm,
mit wenigen unterschiedlichen Wörtern äh halt völlig in einem völlig unterschiedlichen Licht erscheinen lassen.
Gut, kommen wir zum Thema äh Abmahnungen, was wir ja hier äh schon hatten in der vorletzten Ausgabe, ne, hatten wir den,
unseren Gast Ronny, genau.
Kraftfuttermischwerk war da und erzählte uns von den Abmahnungen und ein weiteres Abmahnoffer ähm nämlich der äh Herr Herr MC Winkel, wahrscheinlich MC.
Der MC Winkel. Der MC Winkel äh lässt sich das nicht gefallen, ja und äh äh sagt äh, dass also der sollte also abgemahnt werden,
ohne rechtliche Grundlage, das heißt, er war einer von denen, die also eine Abmahnung erhalten haben, gesagt haben, wie kommst du dazu, irgendwie dieses Recht für dich zu beanspruchen? Dann musste diese MGM Press ähm ihren,
ihren Anspruch zurückziehen. Ähm,
und da sagt er, denke ich, stellt er korrekt fest, man wollte mich und viele weitere äh Blogger betrügen, wenn nicht sogar erpressen. Und genau daher gibt's jetzt eine Strafanzeige zurück,
Und der hat also jetzt Strafantrag gestellt ähm gegen die äh Abmahnagentur HGMpress Michel OHG.
Und die Abmahnanwälte von Active Law. Ähm ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
ob er das jetzt wegen Nötigung oder tatsächlich gegen Erpressung ah ja, Tatbestand einer Erpressung ja.
Also er sagt, es gibt einen, es gibt also ein Urteil, auf das er äh verlinkt, ähm wo ein Abmander Erpresser immer abmachende Anwalt, immerhin wegen Erpressung angeklagt wurde, ja. Ähm.
Aber nicht verurteilt wurde.
Das ist sogar sein Fall. Na ja, also okay, offensichtlich, alles klar. Er hat den jetzt wegen äh wegen Erpressung angeklagt. Ich bin mal gespannt, ob er damit durchkommt.
Interessante Sichtweise auf jeden Fall. Aber da ist ja auch was dran, also in der Sichtweise meine ich, meiner Meinung nach.
Ja, es es ist auf jeden Fall, also so oder so, ich meine, das sollen das sollen Leute machen, die das, die das studiert haben, aber so oder so kann es auf jeden Fall nicht in Ordnung sein, was die da machen,
ähm und äh irgendwas irgendwas Betrug oder Erpressung oder sonstiges Verwerfliches, ist das sicherlich. Und äh das sollen dann die Anwälte klären, was es genau ist und da entsprechend,
den den Sack zumachen.
Gut, wir bleiben dran. Das äh finde ich, ehrlich gesagt, ganz spannend. Äh keine Ahnung, ob das irgendeine Erfolgsaussicht hat, aber äh wenn's hier mal zu einer interessanten Entscheidung kommen würde, das würde der ganzen Debatte doch sehr äh behilflich sein, ne.
Das Abmahnwesen. Ist ja auch noch so ein Aspekt, den man äh vollkommen unerwähnt gelassen, als wir vorhin nur über das Leistungsschutzrecht und die Debatte gesprochen haben. Das wurde früher auch gesagt.
Petra Sitte, erwähnte das, ja, dass die.
Ja dann auch Türentor öffnet und würde das dann auch tatsächlich passieren, dann würde, glaube ich, auch äh die Stimmung da auch sehr schnell kippen.
Ähm.
Das Thema jetzt nicht wieder aufmachen.
Hatte, glaube ich, eh kein Thema mehr aufwachen. Ähm eine Sache wollten wir, glaube ich, noch kurz erwähnen, oder?
Ja, wollten wir.
Und zwar der der große Gregor Seedlack, der große Gregor Sedlack, äh einer der besten unserer Zeit.
Ähm.
Ich glaube dreimal CRE Gast, ne oder oder viermal sogar,
Also poststrukturalismus eins und zwei und Peri Rode an.
Genau.
Der der große periode Anzeichner Gregor Sedlack ähm konnte dafür gewonnen werden für den Verein Digitale Gesellschaft. Äh ein Comic zu zeichnen,
der den Titel trägt, die Liga der Internetschuhe,
und in Form eines ähm,
eines äh eines Adventskalenders veröffentlicht wird. Man kann da sehen, wie jeden Tag heute ist, übrigens der erste Dezember, das heißt, wie ich habe mir gerade die ersten drei Bilder des Comics angeschaut.
Ersten Restrips.
Die ersten drei Strips. Ich bin da ich bin da überhaupt nicht bewandert, wie man was man da jetzt, wie man das benennt. Also in die ganzen Vokabeln des Comictums kenne ich gar.
Ich auch nicht, aber es äh sozusagen sind's halt so drei Tripty-Shows da, ne.
Also Bilder, lustige Bilder mit mit Texten und es geht äh ziemlich absurd los und äh und und irgendwie auch überhaupt nicht absurd. Ist auf jeden Fall lustig und,
Ich bin gespannt, wie dieser Comic weitergeht und ich bin froh, dass ich mir gar nicht angeguckt habe, weil der lag irgendwann letztens bei Markus aufm Tisch. Ähm als ich damals zu Besuch war. Ähm auch hier natürlich wieder der Disclaper, ich äh,
Bei Gregor Seelag auf dem Geburtstag eingeladen und er bei mir.
Wirklich.
Das weißt du doch.
Naja.
Äh wir haben uns zu beiden Angelegenheiten gehört. Tim nehme ich auch. Ich kann bezeugen, dass Tim bei beiden Veranstaltungen auch zugegen war,
und ähm.
Wir sind so befangen.
Und außerdem äh ist das eine Subtomate von digitaler Gesellschaft DE. Äh der Verein, in dem ich auch irgendwie.
Ja, es sind ja alles miteinander verfilzt und verwoben. Ja, ja, glaubt uns nicht.
Ein Filz, das ist der Lobby Filz der Netzgemeinde, ja? Ganz widerlich.
Glaubt uns nichts. Ja Linus.
Ja, man sieht, dass es wieder viel zu früh war für uns, ne.
Och, es geht so, ich bin eigentlich relativ fit.
Ich nicht, ich bin müde. Ich bin müde.
Schon. Ja, aber weitere Dinge stehen an und äh um die muss nicht gekümmert werden, insofern sage ich mal, das war's.
Haut rein.
Bis bald, tschüss.